cyberpunk
2077 it has received a next-gen upgrade
as well as a whole bunch of fixes which
begs the question
is cyberpunk properly
playable now to help me answer that
question i've got john luke sipki with
me who has been playing the updated
version of cyberpunk for the last day or
so hi john luke hey yeah i've been
checking out the ps5 version as well as
the pc version with the uh 1.5 patch
update and my initial impression after a
day with it is that this is the version
of cyberpunk that should have been
released at launch it feels like it's
finally a mostly
complete experience from a technical
standpoint i realized that
is kind of faint praise it's a pretty
low bar to me be set but
it's you know that's kind of where we're
at with cyberpunk but yeah it feels like
it's finally playable yeah because i
played it on playstation i was playing
on ps5 but obviously i was playing the
ps4 version
i was still you know subject to a lot of
crashes i know you said you played the
pc version too but let's hit it off with
the playstation 5 version because
playstation
is where a lot of the issues were
obviously leading it to being taken from
the playstation store and obviously
there's a little bit of hubbub that it's
not as easy to upgrade the ps4 version
to ps5
as it is on xbox where smart delivery
just does it all for you um and also on
the playstation 5 version new trophies
because it's not even the same trophy
list no no trophies which is a real
shame uh because it's a new trophy list
so you don't get that fun satisfaction
of watching all the trophies pop in for
you when you load in your save uh yeah
you gotta do the usual thing that's just
sort of a part of the playstation
ecosystem at this point we have to
download a whole new thing uh thankfully
my saves were able to download um
without any worry so i could just
immediately pop in and yeah the ps5
version is pretty great so it has two
modes that offers a performance mode
where the game will run at 60fps at a
dynamic 4k as well as a ray tracing mode
where it'll run at a 30 fps with a
dynamic 4k in my experience the
performance mode is fantastic it is an
open world game so i can't speak to how
consistent the dips are throughout the
entire game's experience you know it i'm
sure there's going to be spots where it
dips but in my time with it yesterday it
was
smooth as butter
and i really do think the performance
mode is the way to play because the ray
tracing mode while it is 30 fps uh i
think john lennon from digitalfoundry on
twitter actually described it really
well it feels very heavy
you know it's a little sluggish in the
way it moves it doesn't have that like
smooth 30 in the way maybe some other
games do and then to be honest like the
the uh visual enhancements from the ray
tracing are a little disappointing they
went with ray tray shadows over
reflections or ray trace lighting ray
tray shadows are probably the least
noticeable upgrade i really doubt most
people are gonna even tell there's a
difference sure if you do side by side
you'll be like oh yeah i can see those
shadows there but you know where like
reflections are a little bit more flashy
and personally raytraced lighting in my
opinion is probably one of the most
impressive things about ray tracing so
i'm kind of bummed that console players
don't get a chance to experience that i
almost wish that they had another mode
that would actually like just put the
game at like 1080p so that you could
maybe experience ray tracing but that's
being nitpicky on my part it still works
and runs fine for the most part but yeah
if you're going to play it definitely
play it on the performance mode that
that 60 fps that is where it is at i
remember one of the big criticisms was
that the world didn't necessarily feel
as alive as we've come to expect have
you noticed like more crowd density like
what are the roads like driving have you
noticed any big changes there i would
say it feels
natural and normal they've added a bunch
of improvements they've said to ai with
a like tweaking crowd ai as well as
tweaking like combat ai when you're
playing it you can't immediately tell oh
how different is this really it's more
that you don't notice it right it's not
in the way anymore like when you play
the game originally it's like okay i'm
constantly noticing all these issues
with the lack of crowd or people popping
in that was just immersion breaking and
that is no longer a thing that i have
noticed when i was just playing the ps5
version naturally i mean look it's still
a video game like i'm sure there are
going to be people who have found ways
to like notice weird issues with it but
where before i would just be playing the
game and all these things were popping
up
just playing it naturally now i'm not
thinking about that stuff anymore which
is really kind of like what you want
yeah exactly that's that's super
exciting that's super encouraging
because yeah i remember there were a lot
of memes
uh coming out of like people just
watching the crowd reactions to if there
was a gunfight in the streets um what
other before we move on to the pc
version what are the big takeaways from
the ps5 version have you noticed like
have they done anything with like dual
sense that kind of thing to really
make it feel like a next-gen version oh
yeah yeah they uh they're taking full
advantage of the dual sense which is
kind of neat so now a lot of your little
like tech sound effects actually play
out in the dual sense controller which
is neat so like when you get like a
phone call or anything like that of
course you can turn that stuff off they
also have the adaptive triggers which
are fine to be honest i actually kind of
found them a little annoying um but you
can just go ahead and turn them off but
yeah like they have all that stuff there
they also have activities which is cool
so you know you can use that thing yeah
they they went full in with uh adding
all of like the next-gen features you'd
expect with like a proper ps5 version so
in terms of the pc version how did that
stack up after this update really well
for me i'm running the game on a 2080 ti
and when i played it back at launch
i could get it to run but it just was
kind of hitching a lot of spots just
felt very poorly optimized playing it
now felt like a night and day difference
and just how smooth it felt i imagine
that's the case of not just this one
update but sort of like a cumulative all
the updates they've been applying over
the last year but at least for me it
felt like it was just way more optimized
for my pc now i have heard from other
people i was kind of like looking at the
reddit and seeing if anyone was having
issues with it apparently there are
still some technical issues that people
have been having as far as like you know
the game like not running well on their
computer feeling like someone was saying
they actually thought it was worse
optimized so
it's just kind of the nature of pc games
is you know can't really account for
everyone's setup but it seems like for
the most part that is more the exception
than the rule where it used to be with
cyberpunk and i would say in my
experience it feels very very smooth uh
but it's obviously not just like the
improvements to how the game runs and
how the game looks they've put in a lot
of quality of life changes and
improvements in even looking at those
patch notes was so daunting i think the
big uh the big ones that stuck out to me
were the
fact that v can change appearance get
apartments
what what are the big things that left
out at you when you when you booted up
after about a year away so for me
actually the biggest thing that i
noticed up front was the map that was
the thing that got me the most excited
if you remember last year we made a
video where we talked about the
improvements we wanted to see in the
game and one of them was how that map
was just a complete mess of icons yeah
so they've actually gone ahead and
redone a lot of the icons to make them
more visually distinct from one another
no longer is buying a car the same icon
as a quest so you're no longer like
confused about that you can also
actually uh go in and customize what you
want to be shown as well as i give you a
couple presets for options so overall i
think that plus a bunch of other tweaks
you can see like how many quests you've
done for this particular fixer small
stuff like that just kind of compounds
over and it it
has a much more pleasant user experience
as you're navigating the menus they've
redone the whole game economy in a lot
of ways with the way shops work as well
as clothing will actually have a lot of
better stats and they've reworked like
stuff you can sell to ripper docks that
is a hard thing to gauge
how much of an impact that truly has on
the game after only one day of playing
you really need to play through the
whole game but just from my initial
impressions of it it is a lot stronger
and i find myself where in the original
game i didn't even bother with the
economy because it just it felt so
unnecessary it feels like they're really
taking steps to improve that and i'm
curious to see how people kind of
evaluate it like as they replay through
the game properly but it feels like
they're taking the right steps to
address that kind of stuff and what
about driving oh i thought driving felt
way smoother i immediately noticed a
difference in it it didn't have like the
swimminess to it yeah i have had some
people say they actually think it's
worse which i think is just a case of
driving in video games is so subjective
from person to person but at least in my
experience i immediately noticed a
difference and i was like yes this feels
better to me
they've also talked a lot about things
like the ai with like combat and you
know we mentioned like crowd stuff and
kind of what i said before which is i
can't truly tell like is this ai
better
hard to say without like really like
deep diving and doing like a big
comparison but as i mentioned before i'm
not noticing the ai the way i used to
i'm not being distracted by the ai which
to me that's the important thing so
maybe it's like a little bit of a
placebo effect where like they say it's
better and i believe them but it feels
better
what about um bugs because obviously i
mean saw a lot of t-posing in the
original release oh my god yeah how's
that been in my experience playing
yesterday on both pc and ps5 i
experienced no bugs at all the most was
i had like a a small
object like pop like like a collision
thing but that's like a normal open
world thing that happens in every video
game that's not to say that there aren't
still bugs in the game uh our very own
aaron sampson talked about how he booted
the game and immediately had like an
invisible wall um and then like uh some
crowds pop in i've definitely seen
threads of people talking about
different bugs they've been having so
i'm not gonna go ahead and say like yep
the game is perfect no video game is
perfect obviously but based on like what
i had before where i was constantly
experiencing hitches visual bugs within
seconds of playing before the fact that
i was able to play a whole day and not
have any bugs to me is a great sign of
where this game is at hell yeah um any
other of the new features we want to
talk about i messed around like they
they let you do things like um reset
your skill tree which is super nice i
popped into like my late game save and
it was sort of like uh i don't know what
to really do with this but i kind of
like reset it just so that i could try
some of the new skills like the knife
throwing that they added which is cool
again that's the kind of stuff that i
won't have a full sense of how it
actually changes the game unless i do a
proper full playthrough but just looking
at other people's experiences people
seem really happy and excited about some
of the changes to that stuff there's
also things like the apartments that
they've added which is great that stuff
is nothing game changing necessarily
like you can buy a cool apartment you
get to walk around in it you can make
some coffee you can smoke a cigarette
which is fun play some guitar really
it's more of just like kind of like a
nice like ambiance like you know putting
you in the world and you get like i
guess like an extra fast travel location
with a stash which is nice
i think for me it's going to be
interesting to see where they go from
here with that because the game is now
in a really good state and it feels like
we're finally ready to like move on from
this chapter of cyberpunk's life
i don't think people are going to forget
about no the state of this game anytime
soon i think that they have a lot of
work to do still to build back that
goodwill absolutely i i think the this
game's buggy like legacy will probably
stick with it for for all time but it
feels like we are now ready to move past
that and so for me it's more like where
are they going to go next what what
what's the dlc going to be like what's
uh the potential expansions that they
you know talked about as far as i'm
aware they're still planning on doing
that stuff and maybe now they can
finally feel ready to move on for that
and i think this is the perfect
opportunity for
people who have been waiting to finally
go back and check the game like on a on
a personal level i find cyberpunk 2b
still a pretty messy experience overall
just as a game fundamentally you know i
think it's maybe uh has a bit of an
identity crisis where it's like does it
want to be an rpg does it want to be an
open world game i think the story has
got some great highs and lows but the
problem is that it was so hard to
experience that stuff because there was
just that technical barrier and i knew a
lot of people who got the game at launch
or were thinking about getting the game
at launch and then they said you know
what i'm just not even going to touch
this until i know it's in a good state
i'll wait for the next gen update i
don't want to deal with this and that
day is finally here so it feels it feels
like people will actually get to play
and judge the game on its own merits not
just the it's technical merits so um
it's exciting it's exciting that this
game is is uh finally in in a place
where people can do that exactly and for
more on cyberpunk we have a whole lot
about the game on our channel already
including a bunch of lore videos um that
john luke did a couple years ago but
they are still as relevant as ever if
this is your first time jumping into
cyberpunk now that it's been updated or
if you've decided to pick it up again
because of all the changes and they've
got you excited
for more on the game obviously keep it
gamespot and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you